so this was submitted by javi underscore
naz on instagram ryan toy reviews he
made
30 million this year and during his
career
i do not know how long he's been on
youtube for
but he's brought in over 200 million
dollars
i wonder because he has revenue from his
toy
from his toy line hold up he has a toy
line he's his youtube
he has his own video games my son
subscribes to all of it
so the way it works so he'll get on
there and obviously like
he's only nine mil not now he's like 19
now i don't know
he's older than nine now right no he's
nine i looked it up yesterday that's a
big-ass nine-year-old
he's a nightmare my son can watch
youtube
once a week either on saturday sunday he
picks for two hours
but the thing is is he'll get on there
the toy companies will send him like the
new [ __ ]
and so he'll like play with him like
he'll show like on the videos reviews
yeah now his parents can't touch his
money right well it's different because
youtube doesn't follow the same type of
labor laws
that like hollywood yeah in hollywood if
you're under the age of 18 and you make
money it goes into an account that you
can activate once you become a legal
adult
so no one else can touch it yeah it's
all your money youtube
with youtube there isn't really like uh
a child labor laws
let's think about it too is when they
set up the account so when you set up a
youtube account like the money from
finding kid
when i created it i had to give him a
bank account to fund the money into
so the kids when he started probably
four or five so his dad is the one who
set up all the bank account
so that money is just getting deposited
into this bank account you did that
oh you guys salivating you drooled
everywhere
i saw that money our money and i was i
got
he's all you did
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] that's how great this [ __ ] is so
okay i guess that makes sense like
because i mean youtube's not telling him
what videos to make they
yeah he just makes it so that's probably
why they don't have family started that
channel when he was
really young he was just like a kid
unboxing stuff and his parents would
record him put it on youtube
he got a huge following i think he
currently has 27 people he's older than
nine
bring it up how old is ronnie what's his
name because he
he had a show on nickelodeon too yeah he
sure did he's older
i'm nine he's nine he's just lit makeup
yesterday
he's nine yeah go to images with makeup
go say well i saw him on nickelodeon he
looks like a like a third i mean we
can't tell which one's the
newest one you wanna just go to his
youtube channel right now oh my god same
time wait until tiger's night tyree's
gonna look so much older than mine
hey why's he might just be one of those
kids why is that lady holding up
his parents are open the video oh this
she was uh she went to
jail for some sort of fraud or something
i forgot what it was
i don't know but yeah his parents have
said in videos before that
they set aside a lot of the money so he
can go to college and like he has money
college
for what if he wants to go to college
he's nine call
you mean the one month salary on youtube
would pay for college mm-hmm
the [ __ ] i'd be like call you give my
[ __ ] money
you better buy me a house in the hidden
hills account for him
just like set up don't worry we started
a college fund for ryan he's like
[ __ ] one video paid for college i know
right also i'm going for college for
what
yeah communication whatever he wants but
like you go to college he's a career
yeah but emma watson the actress from
harry potter she stopped acting because
she wanted to go to brown she wanted to
receive an education there are actors
like that i don't see that
i don't see that for ryan you don't see
that ryan's future i mean
i mean if my kid was making 60 million a
year what the [ __ ] it was like you why
i mean if you want to go to college you
have fun you know yeah what if he wants
to do that
just be a regular experience yeah maybe
you know what's crazy about this is he
he still gets to be a kid yeah which is
cool you know what i mean like he
doesn't have to worry about like
fame yeah he's the most famous you're
not fame i'm talking about like uh
you know these kids like they'll act in
these shows yeah and they can't go to
regular they can't do it
they can't no you come home after school
and knock out one of these videos like
he's playing with toys like
what a kid does he's not on sale for
like 16 hours kids aren't like reviewing
toys and [ __ ] where can i buy his merch
merch he has his own like mario kart uh
he's his own mario kart i seriously yeah
he has whole lines and uh where can i
buy his merch okay i saw his shirt
it looked pretty hard how much is this
match yeah i like his heart sure
let me see wow that's on target and
walmart
oh this guy's making buku money
they even talked about his uh merch line
they don't miss off youtube they don't
make it in adults
you can't you said the article said that
youtube limits their advertising on kids
videos
youtube limits the advertising and kids
videos i think they're stricter with
what um is qualified as a
like kids content because before as long
as you checked a certain box and said if
you were making content for kids
they let you have advertisements like
whatever oh
and now well i'm seeing products that
generate more than 200 million
yeah almost drew it again god damn it
[ __ ] we got to get on youtube his
parents are like we are on youtube we're
sending you to college
not the same one we're going to send you
college don't wear your college paid for
but
that's crazy good for good for them good
for him his family
you got a full ride to devry they live
in texas yeah they live in texas
so not paying taxes either oh he's
getting
all that money all that money his
parents are
his parents why can't you just assume
his parents are shitty
yeah what if that yeah you don't know
you're pretty defensive with this kid
cat
you just like to [ __ ] on the parents i'm
not sure i don't i don't trust them no
you don't trust his parents i don't
trust parents though why
making 40 million dollars a year if you
were making that much money off of tiger
would you
take his money i wouldn't let tiger make
those videos i wouldn't put my kid i
would horn my kid out like that
so already i i'm questioning their
ethics already
when you're that's a fair thing you're
pouring your kid out and you know how
many videos he has how many and then
he's on nickelodeon the dad's on
nickelodeon
i'm just saying we've seen this story
how many times in hollywood it doesn't
end well
that's a fair that's i think that's fair
but the tiger was like dad can you set
up the set so we can crank out these
videos
like if he wanted to do him like i guess
but they're building an empire though
no it's working yeah all right
shout out to ryan man i don't know how
that story ends for him you know
hopefully well hopefully well yeah oh
yeah mccolly culligan
he's doing great he's doing as good as
he can be i think
great's all relative my man
his parents still like all his money oh
yeah yeah yeah that's when that law came
right
yeah yeah with like were your parents
kicked did britney spears get out her uh
no her dad owns brittany britney started
as a kid
yeah but i'm saying still to his date
yeah i think the
the court made some uh decision with
regarding the father
yeah he he he owns everything everything
power over
she can't see her kids huh i don't know
what's going on no no
how [ __ ] up is she i don't know we
don't know like what she's doing that's
the thing
like we know she's not doing great but
we don't know the severity of like
that's the thing that you know the law
gave the father power of turning and the
kids and
the things it must be really bad they're
they're just not going to do what's
crazy is that like
people only know a surface level of the
story and we just
they just know based on social media so
all these people think it's like
oh this is what it is like she's getting
[ __ ] over like you know
[ __ ] and that's right really knows yeah
because i heard she went crazy for a
little bit
she did cut her hair but she's not she's
not normal even right now
i just it's hard to watch what she does
it's like she's just there like
like a vessel yeah but that everyone
around her is you know having her do
stuff
damn and that's how it ended for these
childhood actress you know been in the
game for a minute well hopefully it
works out for ryan though
yeah i hope so he's not a child actor
well he kind of is yes sean nicholson
yeah
yeah yeah like a certain extent he is in
that life yeah he's so famous
i'm glad i'm glad i moved to l.a at 31
years old
i can't imagine being i could not
imagine like being any younger than that
think about that i think about the
issues uh justin bieber has yeah
he grew up in front of the camera he
seems good now yeah
because he found god i mean just saying
a [ __ ] song about how terrible his
childhood was
it's a great song lonely yeah that's
good oh really yeah the video is good
where his parents mean to him
didn't that guy don't think his parents
were his dad's kind of a piece of [ __ ]
really
that guy i think they had a weird
relationship because good guys
uh started starting uh his lonely video
shoot the little white guy looked just
like him and good guys
and good guys weird guys well hopefully
uh he was in room he was the little boy
in room
with uh brie larson i didn't see him
uh i think you can get it on any like
streaming platform well bieber if you
need a homie to talk to man actually
she did yeah oh she's a beast by the way
and that's a great actor i respect he
was he was
i didn't i didn't realize he had a
[ __ ] up childhood i thought his
parents
his parents i believe married and had
kids really young
they weren't really stable then he kind
of popped off and they had separated so
it kind of affected him
getting famous yeah good boys i'm sorry
good boy
yeah that's him there's a lot he's a how
about that when i get off stage at the
lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this wrote a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son